Klassische Optimierung ist ein entscheidender Schritt in klassisch-quantenmechanischen Algorithmen
wie dem variationellen Quanten-Eigenlöser oder dem Quanten-Maschinellen Lernen.
Allerdings erweist es sich oft als schwierig, zu minimieren
komplizierte Funktionen in hochdimensionalen Parameterräumen.
Mein Name ist Victoria Lipinska, und in diesem Video erkunden wir
klassische Optimierungsverfahren für klassisch-quantenmechanische Algorithmen.
Optimierungsprobleme sind nicht einfach.
Je mehr Parameter es gibt, desto größer wird auch die Anzahl der möglichen
Wertkombinationen – und zwar exponentiell.
Im Schach zum Beispiel gibt es 64 Felder,
jeder Spieler hat 16 Figuren – nachdem jeder Spieler eine einzige Figur bewegt hat,
gibt es 400 verschiedene Stellungen. Nach zwei Zügen 72.084 Stellungen,
nach drei Zügen rund 9 Millionen und nach
vier Zügen rund 280 Milliarden.
Wenn wir nur 40 Züge erreichen, wird die Anzahl möglicher Stellungen
auf etwa zehn hoch 120 geschätzt.
Ein perfektes Spiel zu spielen würde erfordern, alle möglichen
Stellungen zu erkunden – und dieses enorme Wachstum bedeutet, dass es
schlicht nicht machbar ist, alle Stellungen einzeln durchzugehen.
Das lässt sich lösen, indem man das Problem in zwei kleinere Teilprobleme aufteilt.
Erstens müssen wir bestimmen, welche Schachbrettkonstellationen
in zukünftigen Spielschritten wahrscheinlich auftreten werden.
Das nennen wir unseren relevanten Teilraum.
Und zweitens müssen wir, gegeben diesen Teilraum, den besten Zug bestimmen.
Das nennen wir unseren besten Zug.
In dieser Analogie entspricht die anfängliche Suche durch den relevanten Teilraum
unserem klassischen Optimierungsalgorithmus.
Sobald dieser relevante Teilraum bekannt ist,
ist meist ein Quantenalgorithmus dafür zuständig, den besten Zug zu finden,
gegeben diesen Teilraum.
Fangen wir damit an, nur einen Parameter zu betrachten,
Theta, der eine Kostenfunktion parametrisiert, die wir optimieren möchten.
Wenn wir die Funktion plotten – sie sieht etwa so aus –,
haben wir auf der X-Achse die Werte des Parameters Theta
und auf der Y-Achse die Kostenfunktion.
Bedenke, dass die Kostenfunktion tatsächliche finanzielle Kosten sein könnten,
die wir minimieren wollen, oder – wie es beim variationellen Quanten-Eigenlöser
häufig der Fall ist – eine Energie, die von der Natur minimiert wird.
Unser Ziel ist es, das Theta zu finden,
das den niedrigsten Kosten entspricht.
Wir starten mit einem Anfangswert von Theta und finden in jedem Optimierungsschritt
ein neues Theta, das die Kosten weiter reduziert.
Es scheint, als wüssten wir ziemlich leicht, in welche Richtung wir im Graphen gehen sollen, wenn wir ihn sehen können.
Aber die Schwierigkeit bei der Optimierung ist, dass wir das eigentlich nicht wissen.
Wir erfahren immer nur die Kosten – ein winziges Stück des gesamten Puzzles –,
sobald wir die Funktion für das gewählte Theta auswerten.
So funktioniert Optimierung im Allgemeinen.
Der Optimierer sampelt Parameter-Theta-Werte und berechnet die Kosten.
Wie du dir vorstellen kannst, ist es nicht sehr effizient, Theta zufällig zu wählen,
um die gesamte Topologie der Funktion zu rekonstruieren.
Stattdessen berechnen clevere Optimierer in jedem Schritt
den Gradienten der Funktion.
So weiß der Optimierer, in welche Richtung im Plot
er gehen muss, um die niedrigsten Kosten zu finden.
Sobald der Gradient null ist, terminiert der Algorithmus
und das Minimum ist gefunden.
Dieses Minimum muss nicht das globale Minimum sein.
Es kann sich um ein lokales Minimum handeln,
also den kleinsten Wert der Kostenfunktion in der Umgebung,
aber nicht über den gesamten Wertebereich von Theta.
Bei einem Parameter ist das durchaus möglich.
Je mehr Parameter wir aber haben,
desto komplizierter wird die Funktion.
Schon bei zwei Parametern haben wir eine Fläche,
und bei vier Parametern lässt sie sich gar nicht mehr zeichnen.
Genau wie im Schach-Beispiel wird es sehr schnell
unlösbar komplex.
Wir sehen, dass es schwierig ist, komplizierte Funktionen
in hochdimensionalen Parameterräumen zu minimieren.
Um dennoch sinnvolle Ergebnisse zu erzielen, sollen klassische Optimierungsverfahren
sowohl schnell als auch präzise sein.
Sie müssen außerdem robust gegenüber Rauschen sein,
das bei nahezu verfügbaren Quantencomputern erhebliche Auswirkungen haben wird.
Klassische Optimierungsalgorithmen lassen sich grob einteilen
in zwei Klassen: direkte Suchmethoden und gradientenbasierte Methoden.
Gradientenbasierte Methoden benötigen Informationen über den Gradienten
der Funktion während des Optimierungsprozesses.
Dieser kann entweder analytisch berechnet
oder durch eine Finite-Differenzen-Berechnung approximiert werden.
Direkte Suchmethoden verwenden keine Gradienteninformationen
und nutzen andere Strategien, um die Kostenfunktion zu minimieren.
Einige der am häufigsten verwendeten Optimierungsalgorithmen
im Quantencomputing-Umfeld sind die folgenden Optimierer.
COBYLA steht für „Constrained Optimization by Linear Approximation"
und ist ein gradientenfreier Optimierungsalgorithmus.
SLSQP steht für „Sequential Least Squares Programming",
ein gradientenbasierter Optimierungsalgorithmus.
Er verwendet einen stochastischen Störvektor,
um gleichzeitig einen approximierten Gradienten der Kostenfunktion zu berechnen.
In einer rauschfreien Umgebung konvergieren Optimierer wie COBYLA
und SLSQP nachweislich schneller als SPSA.
Klassische Optimierer haben ihre eigenen Parameter,
die du für bestimmte Fälle festlegen kannst, zum Beispiel die Schrittweite.
Diese sind in der Regel in der Dokumentation zum
jeweiligen Optimierer zu finden.
Ich empfehle dir, die Referenzliste unten für einen Vergleich
der aktuellsten klassischen Optimierer zu prüfen.
Lass uns noch ein weiteres Phänomen im Zusammenhang
mit der klassischen Optimierung parametrisierter Quanten-circuits erkunden.
Wie wir bereits gesehen haben, kann ein verschwindender Gradient der Kostenfunktion darauf hinweisen,
dass der Optimierer auf einem Plateau ohne interessante Merkmale gelandet ist – einem sogenannten
„Barren Plateau".
Ein Barren Plateau kann viele Ursachen haben.
Der Gradient der Kostenfunktion eines Quanten-circuits
mit zufällig initialisierten Parametern
fällt mit der Anzahl der qubits exponentiell auf null ab.
Das liegt daran, dass der vom Optimierer erkundete Quantenraum
exponentiell groß wird, wenn die Anzahl der qubits steigt.
Zu den Möglichkeiten, dieses Problem anzugehen, gehört die Reduzierung der Parameteranzahl
und damit der Dimension des zugrunde liegenden Raums.
Eine weitere Perspektive auf den Ursprung des Barren-Plateau-Problems
ist die problemagnostische Natur des parametrisierten circuits,
der mit einem exponentiell großen Parameterraum konfrontiert ist.
Einen circuit so zu gestalten, dass er auf das betrachtete
Problem zugeschnitten ist, könnte eine gute Lösung sein.
Neben dem exponentiellen Parameterraum, der Barren Plateaus erzeugt,
können auch andere physikalische Phänomene sie verursachen:
das Rauschen und die Dekohärenz in Quantencomputing-Experimenten,
die Ausdrucksstärke des parametrisierten circuits insgesamt,
oder die Nichtlokalität und der Grad der Verschränkung der modellierten Kostenfunktion.
Die Bewältigung dieser Herausforderungen ist weiterhin ein aktives Forschungsgebiet.
Nachdem wir nun die wesentlichen Komponenten von VQE besprochen haben,
fassen wir den Algorithmus im nächsten Video zusammen.